collègues députés qu'il faut le demander
j'ai utilisé ce matin une métaphore pour
la première ministre en disant soit
c'est la roulette russe c'est-à-dire il
y a pas de 49-3 elle essaie de faire en
sorte que elle a une majorité auquel cas
elle fait ce pari ça peut être un pari
bien calculé mais aujourd'hui ça
ressemble un peu à la route à la
roulette russe soit c'est le 49-3
c'est-à-dire la Grosse Bertha et
aujourd'hui moi je ne sais pas dire je
suis sénateur je suis président d'un
groupe au Sénat et je ne sais pas dire
qu'elle peut-être demain une majorité
pour ce texte là-bas à l'Assemblée
nationale
où on a du mal à suivre la ligne de
votre partie aujourd'hui vous vous
faites tout pour voter cette loi eux
nous explique qu'ils n'auront pas les
voies suffisantes pour donner la
majorité au gouvernement les députés de
votre partie on a un peu du mal à suivre
la ligne de votre de votre partie
aujourd'hui
du parti elle est très claire la
direction aussi Olivier Marleix et
moi-même nous l'avons exprimé à
plusieurs reprises il y a 61 députés
est-ce qu'il y aura l'abstention le con
de 15 ou de 20 j'observe que le gros de
l'équipe de Olivier Marleix votre
apourse cette réforme est-ce que ça
suffira moi je ne sais pas je peux pas
faire des comptes d'apothicaire
aujourd'hui d'ici en plus du Sénat
moi j'ai toujours dit ici que
on peut pas varier je pense que ce qui a
beaucoup abîmé les LR c'est nos recul
nous revirements de quoi aurions-nous
l'air si une voiture pas ce texte 74 ans
alors que depuis des années on soutient
65 ans il faut améliorer le texte les
députés l'ont fait nous l'avons fait
collectivement sur les petites pensions
sur les carrières longues nous faisons
aussi par exemple sur les maires de
famille je pense que la politique même
quand c'est pas populaire c'est dire la
vérité aux Français et la vérité
française c'est que on a un choc
démographique sans précédent c'est plus
le baby-boom c'est le papy boom c'est à
dire qu'on va multiplier par 4 par 5 le
nombre de françaises de Français qui
vont entrer dans la période de la
retraite comment fait-on pour financer
tout ça comment fait-on aussi on accepte
pas de travailler un peu plus et bien on
fait exploser le régime par répartition
et je voudrais simplement dire que en
2030 quand cette réforme s'a ppliquera
nous serons le pays d'Europe où on
partira le plus tôt en retraite nous
serons le pays d'Europe où nous aurons
le meilleur régime de carrière longue de
toute l'Europe